it's great to be here over the years
I've used a lot of these software this
is my first time at Pi data but I've
listened to a lot of high data talks
online on YouTube so it's great to be
here and thanks to Pi data and I'm
focused for organizing this wonderful
conference so today I'm going to talk
about causal machine learning for a
smart paywall at the new up times and
I'm going to start out by giving a brief
introduction of the technological
transformation and data science at the
New York Times and then moving to a
specific project that I personally
worked on as a data scientist for
machine learning for the New York Times
paywall and because we're at Pi data I
also want to tell you a little bit about
our Tech stack and how we do make use of
Open Source tools to power these machine
learning models for the New York Times
Table
and before I begin I want to start out
by acknowledging the people who have
played a huge role in the project that
I'm going to talk about
um Chris Wiggins who is a chief data
scientist at the New York Times he also
happens to be a professor at Columbia in
applied math
and Bauer who is the executive director
of data science and is the team lead for
the team I'm working on I believe she is
in the audience today
um has a background in astrophysics and
Heidi Jiang who is a senior data
scientist who is my colleague who I work
very closely with in building machine
learning models for the paywall so all
of these people have had huge
contributions to the project that I'm
going to talk about and in particular I
want to thank Chris Wiggins for some of
the slides that he has very kindly given
me and so that I can talk about them
so because data science has a lot of
different meanings today I thought it'd
be a good idea to start out by talking
about what we mean by data science and
how we think about it and for that it's
helpful to think about this Venn diagram
that Drew Conway came up with in 2010
where data science can be thought of as
a merger of three different areas so you
have hacking skills math and statistics
knowledge and substantive experience and
hacking skills doesn't mean your ability
to hack a website it means interesting
technological solutions that you can
come up with for complex problems at
speed and that's what hacking skills
means and it's very important for data
science math and statistics knowledge of
course not news that that's important
because all machine learning models and
algorithms have a strong mathematical
and statistical foundation so you want
to understand them it's better to have
that knowledge and substantive expertise
which in the industry context means
understanding of a business problem so
that you can translate it to machine
learning objectives that you can
optimize for and then there's a very
real danger zone which is at the merger
of whoops
which is at the merger of hacking skills
and substantive expertise where you know
we can appeal to this old saying where
if you torture the data enough you can
just start making it tell a story
whatever you want and that's true
because there's a lot of packages and a
lot of Open Source data sets available
these days and if you have enough
substantive expertise you can build
hacky solutions that work for a few
months but don't stand the test of time
and so we do want to take into account
math and statistics to move away from
the danger zone and go into this data
science happy field
so many of you probably already know
this and are wondering well what does it
have to do with the newspaper the New
York Times and I think that's a valid
question if you think of the New York
Times like this so this is the first
issue of the New York Times from 1851 uh
so it's a good reminder that it's a very
old company it's 170 year old company
and the company is an incumbent in the
age of this technological transformation
and so it's a challenge to stay relevant
in this day and age and that's been a
challenge for a lot of different U.S
newspapers as well and we can get a
glimpse of that through this chart which
shows the advertising revenue of
different streams and one thing to note
is this blue line which is the ad
revenue of all U.S newspapers and we can
see that after 2005 going up to 2018 it
is continuously Decline and a lot of the
advertising dollars have gone to
Facebook and Google and the exponential
increase in advertising dollars has
basically taken away from the
advertising dollars of U.S newspapers
and advertising dollars is the primary
revenue source at least in the last the
2000s on which U.S newspapers used to
function so this is a challenge and this
was obviously a challenge for the New
York Times
um as well and the New York Times has
leveraged Innovation and Technology a
lot to tackle this challenge head on an
example of this is this 96 page
Innovation report by the times in 2014
and you can read all about it because it
was an internal report but it was
promptly leaked to BuzzFeed so you can
Google and read a lot about it and if
you go through it you will see repeated
mentions of why we need to use
technology and understand reader
behavior and how they interact with the
products to take it into account for
product Innovation and that deeply uh is
is
um is a base for data science as well
because we do want to use data from
readers and how they interact with their
products to build machine learning
solutions to power our KPS
this innovation has worked a lot so now
we have a number of different products
uh within the up times has of course we
have a website and the website has about
90 million unique U.S visitors per month
uh in an atypical month like this month
because of Elections we have much more
number of unique U.S visitors there are
150 pieces of original journalism per
day
uh there are a lot of different
Standalone products like cooking wire
cutter games uh podcasts and Standalone
products like cooking and games have
more than 1 million subscriptions each
and for nyd podcasts we have about 181
million users who have listened to an
nyd podcast in 2021 so there's a lot of
interaction with different nyt products
and so clearly we have a lot of data and
we have millions of readers and
subscribers and so we can use this data
to do some interesting machine learning
and build models that can be actually
productionized
but it's definitely a question as to how
all these different products are
financially supported because to develop
this content uh there is a 2000 people
uh Newsroom uh and they develop this
content and finances have to have to be
balanced and to answer that question we
can again look at this graph of the New
York Times Revenue in terms of
subscription and advertising so the plot
that I showed you about advertising
earlier for all U.S newspapers it
applies to the New York Times as well
because after 2005 going forward
advertising revenue of the New York
Times has also decreased but at the same
time you can see that the subscription
Revenue has continuously increased and I
want to point your attention to this
moment in 2011 when the subscription
Revenue crossed the advertising revenue
and if you if you if you peek at the if
you take a look at the the graph you can
see that the slope changes a bit so
there's a big jump in 2011 and the
subscription Revenue increased quite a
lot annually
and the reason for that is that in 2011
the New York Times launched its paywall
so it started introducing this digital
subscription model so in 2011 March of
2011 it launched paywall and there was a
design decision that was made to have
this paywall as a metered payroll so
this is an industry term for a soft
paywall where users get a certain number
of free articles to read per month
before they hit a paywall there are
other websites for example the athletic
which have a hard paywall so you can't
read any content before you start paying
um I want to point your attention to
this concept of meter limit because I'm
going to appeal to that a lot in this
talk which is the number of free
articles that a user gets per month
before they hit the paywall and as you
can see when the paywall was launched we
used to tell people
um how many articles they've enjoyed in
this month and that limit so when the
payroll was launched the meter limit was
20 free articles this month and it
resets the next month when users come
back
there was some initial skepticism when
the paywall was launched um and so I did
a Google Search and just found out these
two articles where the first one says
the New York Times paywall is destined
for failure and the second one goes a
little more into the reasons why the New
York Times paywall will fail and why
it's really dumb fortunately this has
not turned out to be true the New York
Times paywall has worked and over the
years there's been continuous growth in
the number of subscriptions so here in
this chart right from when the payroll
was launched in 2011 to 2021 there's
been continuous growth in subscriptions
for news as well as Standalone products
like games cooking audio and wire cutter
and in fact earlier this year in January
we hit 10 million subscriptions
um there was a goal that we had set for
2025 but due to the acquisition of the
athletic the goal was achieved much
quicker and we hit 10 million
subscriptions and the goal was updated
to 15 million total subscribers by the
end of 2027. so the paywall has worked
and what I want to talk a little bit
about is how data science has helped in
this journey uh not just this growth of
subscriptions but also in terms of other
areas at the New York Times so the data
science team is involved in
and what the data science team does
um is we develop and deploy machine
learning solutions for business and
Newsroom problems using first party data
whenever I tell people I'm a data
scientist at the New York Times they ask
me if I'm involved with the wonderful
infographics for covid or for election
coverage and my answer disappointing is
always no that's all data journalism
that's all amazing and the data science
team does not do that we are promptly on
the business side and The Newsroom side
but we use machine learning to develop
and deploy models that can help the
business and by develop what we mean is
we don't use off-the-shelf package right
away we do rely on them but we have to
build custom machine learning models to
support the business that has a unique
nature of news and deploy means we ship
to production uh we just don't develop
insights these models actually control
what happens on the website or the app
or build guise or slackbots that people
can use at the company
so different teams that exist in the
data science group the first is
algorithmic recommendations uh it builds
machine learning models to power various
packages on the home page and the app to
recommend users interesting articles
based on their previous reading history
we have advertising which builds machine
learning models to show various
advertising segments to users based on
first party data
we have media Innovations team which
sets up marketing campaigns on external
websites like Twitter and Facebook so
that we can advertise our own content so
that the budget of the marketing
campaigns and the target audiences are
set up and then finally we have the
algorithmic targeting team we call it
alter which I'm a part of and and leads
the team who's in the audience
what we are tasked with is to expand our
subscriber base and increase a
subscriber's lifetime value by targeting
them at various uh moments in their
subscription life cycle and today what
I'm going to talk about is one specific
project related to paywalls that I
personally work on in this algorithmic
targeting team and this project is
called the dynamic meter
so the dynamic meter is a prescriptive
machine learning model that sets
personalized meter limits for registered
users for optimizing for our kpis
now when I'm talking about registered
users I need to tell you what I mean by
that and for that I need to use our
subscription funnel
so this is our subscription funnel where
as we go down the subscription funnel
users get more and more access at the
top of the funnel are unregistered users
so they don't have an account with us
they have a certain limit that they can
read after which they are served a
registration wall which prompts them to
register with us and make an account
once they register with us they go into
this registered status where now we can
understand their appetite for times
content better because their activity on
the New York Times website or the app
can be linked to their New York Times
account and we can use this data to
actually do some machine learning
this is all first party data and is
consistent with our privacy policy so
what we are looking at is completely
engagement data how the user products
what articles they read and so on
CE they hit a certain meter limit uh
that is the number of free articles that
the register uses are can use they hit
the paywall and it is this moment that
the dynamic meter controls so the
dynamic meter is tasked with determining
the number of free articles or
particular user based on their activity
to decide when to show them a paywall
and it's really a dynamic meter in that
we can basically tune the number of
articles that they can get from a large
number to a small number and if you get
a small number we apply more payroll
friction and really to conversions when
we apply lesser payroll friction we
don't lead to as many conversions in
terms of subscriptions
so what is the dynamic meter optimized
for exactly the dynamic meter is tasked
with a dual roll it must support our New
York Times Mission as well as goal our
mission is to seek the truth and help
people understand the world so we
definitely don't want to block everybody
because that means that we are not
letting the information get out so we
have that mission but at the same time
we have a business goal which is to
reach 15 million subscribers by 2027 and
we can achieve that by showing people
paywalls so there's this dual objective
problem that we have and what the
dynamic meter does is it optimizes and
balances the trade-off between
engagement and subscriptions that people
have and this can be visualized using
this this chart over here where I'm
visualizing the engagement which can be
measured in terms of average page views
for example and subscriptions which can
be measured in terms of conversion rate
for example and we can visualize this
trade off by running randomized control
trials that we use to train our models
so here in this randomized control trial
we can see this trade off clearly these
orange dots are different data points
that we've collected using an RCT and
once users get more number of free
articles we see that their engagement is
a lot so the number of page views that
they can read is a lot but that also
leads to lesser subscriptions because
we're not showing as many paywalls in
this case but when there are lesser
number of free articles we can see that
the engagement goes down and the
subscriptions is high so there's this
trade-off and what we'd like to do is
optimize for both these objectives at
the same time using this randomized
Control Data
now I mentioned that Dynamic meter is a
prescriptive machine learning model and
might be a right time to just highlight
the differences between predictive and
prescriptive machine learning where
predictive machine learning is all about
what will happen if we don't do an
intervention so in the New York Times
context one problem could be if we have
a user we know about their past
engagement activity on the New York
Times website can we predict the number
of page views that they would have next
month this is a purely predictive
problem because the ground truth is
known so if you predict for somebody
that they're going to have 20 Page views
in the next month and we go to the next
month and the next month actually
happens and they end up having 10 page
views we can compare 10 versus 20 and
realize that well the model was not
great and there's a big error
prescriptive machine learning problems
are slightly different in that in
prescriptive ml we want to answer the
question of what is the best action to
maximize a particular outcome so in the
New York Times context let's say there's
a user they have a past nyt activity and
there are different actions that we can
take in the case of the dynamic meter
the different actions are the different
number of free articles that we can give
them in the next month and what we would
like to know is what is the best action
that we can take let's say we take this
action which is some number of free
articles that we want to give them we
will observe whether the user subscribed
or not but here comes the tricky point
which is that we typically don't know
what would have happened if we actually
took actions one and three and so what
we need to do is really train a model
based on other users for whom these
actions were taken and then for each
user predict what would have happened in
these different counter factual
scenarios and then pick the one which
will give us the kpi that we we want so
that's a slight difference between
predictive machine learning and
prescriptive machine learning and I want
to emphasize that the dynamic meter is a
prescriptive machine learning problem
because they're trying to find this
action that best optimizes the outcome
so what's the high level model for the
dynamic meter
um so this is a causal model because we
are able to predict in these different
counterfactual scenarios what would have
happened so it is learning the causal
impact of the number of free articles on
a user's propensity to subscribe which
meets our business goal and engagement
level which appeals to our mission
so just looking at subscription uh next
month uh we can take a look at this
schematic over here so as a result of
the model what we can do is for each
user for different number of free
articles which are purely illustrative
here we can predict the subscription
propensity at these different levels and
these are different counterfactual
scenarios and we want to pick one of
them we want to assign those number of
free articles in the next month so that
we can maximize the subscription
propensity and in this case what the
model is going to do is just pick the
number of free articles where the
subscription propensity is the maximum
so we can pick these green ticked bars
which are the number of free articles
that we would assign users and we can
see that it can be non-trivial for
certain users for example this one we
can see that the subscription propensity
is maximized at five articles whereas
for other users there might be an
intermediate level at which they are
very highly likely to subscribe and the
model learns that and takes these
actions foreign
so just a quick slide about what I mean
by this in math which sometimes is
helpful to exactly be in the same page
as what we are talking about
so there are two base models that we
train using RCT data so we have
randomized control trial where users get
different number of free articles and so
we collect this data and we have two
objectives so we are trying to predict
those two objectives here so here Pi is
the probability that somebody would
subscribe next month f is any machine
learning model that you can think of x i
are the user features and I is a user
where they belong to the RCT data the
randomized control trial and MCI is the
middle count or the middle limit that I
mentioned which is the number of free
articles a user can get and this is a
causal model because we have decoupled
this treatment variable MC from the X
and your setup and randomize control
trial on this variable MC so we have a
completely random data because of which
we can train a model and actually
predict what would happen if we took
these different actions of these
different meter limits and then there's
another model which is the engagement
model which just predicts the number of
page views that a certain user will have
next month if you give them those number
of free articles
so we have these two objectives
now because this is a dual objective
problem we want to maximize both of them
at the same time we have to combine them
into one and that's how multi-objective
optimization goes we choose the simplest
way where we just take a convex linear
combination of these two objectives by
introducing a weight Factor Delta so
we're just doing Delta times the
subscription propensity plus 1 minus
Delta times the normalized engagement
and here the Delta becomes our friction
knob so what do I mean by that if Delta
is 1 for example we can see that this
objective purely depends on engagement
so what we're trying to do is just
maximize engagement that users will have
with our site if we set Delta to 1 we
are seeing that we are only maximizing
for subscription propensity so when we
tune this Delta we are going from high
engagement to low engagement and low
conversions to high conversions and this
is critical for us so that business can
decide which level of friction we would
like to be and finally because this is a
prescriptive machine learning problem we
want to assign the meter count or the
meter limit for users in the next month
so what we do do is we take this
combined objective function sorry about
that we take this combined objective
function and we just do an ARG Max over
it so we know what would be the score of
individuals a given user in these
different scenarios of different meat
limits and we pick the one that
maximizes that particular objective
so what do the Optimal Solutions look
like so this is a reminder of the slide
that I already showed you where we are
making the point the dynamic meter
optimizes for subscriptions and
engagement and so there are these two
axes and the randomized control trial
data looks like this where if you have
more number of free articles we increase
engagement and lower subscriptions and
these are randomized control trial data
points and if we plot the model points
on here they would look like this so
this is what is called a Pareto front in
dual objective optimization problems
where every single point on this Pareto
front is actually optimal and we can say
that because let's consider a particular
Orange Point and let's look at a
corresponding Black Point right above it
we can see that for the same conversion
rate the Black Point is much better in
terms of Engagement and similarly if you
compare an orange point with a black
point we can see that for the same
engagement level we have more number of
subscriptions so every single point on
this Pareto front is actually optimal is
better than the randomized control trial
data that we have and now it's a
question of which point do we want to
choose which particular location do we
want to be in terms of the paywall
friction that we would like to design
and that's controlled by this number
Delta that I that I showed you earlier
so if Delta is very small we are at this
point so we are getting low
subscriptions and high engagement but
still better than random data and if
Delta is 1 we're getting high
subscriptions and low engagement but
still better than random data
so
before we deploy a model we need to test
its performance on previous data and
when in in prescriptive machine learning
this is an interesting challenge uh and
I'll show you why
so what we would like to answer a
question is if we develop a new model
how would the model have performed if we
had actually used it in the past if it
used it three months ago in deciding the
meter limits for users how would it have
performed and this is tricky because of
course we can't go back in time and if
somebody actually got 10 free articles
we can't change and give them 100 free
articles and then uh you know kind of
Replay replay the past
but we can do something something clever
and interesting where we can look at the
randomized Control Data that we
collected from previous months so in the
randomized control trial data we had
these different users who had gotten
different number of free articles such
as 5 20 1500
and a newly developed model we run on
the previous data and it wants to take
certain actions so it wants to give 20
25 and 50 200 articles for these
different users
so if you look at this green user here
what the model wants to do is give them
20 articles sometime in the past but
they actually got five articles
so we can't really know what would have
happened if the model actually wanted to
give 20 articles in the past so maybe
that's not very useful data but because
we have millions of users in this
randomized control trial that we can run
there are actually cases when just by
random chance the number of articles
that a user got in the past matches with
what the model would have wanted to do
and so this becomes a problem in
statistics of survey sampling where we
know deterministically what the model
wanted to do and then there are random
probabilities for when this match will
occur and this is a classic problem in
service sampling used for election
statistics and so on and we can use this
to estimate the model performance using
a technique called inverse probability
weighting so using this technique we can
then generate a curve like this for
every single month that we would like to
um set the number of free articles for
different different users and we get a
frontier like this where we are tuning
this Delta and we're getting these
different black points and which black
point we want to choose depends on a
conversion rate that the business would
like to Target so if we would like to
achieve a certain number of
subscriptions in the next month we would
choose one particular point and that
would give us a corresponding conversion
rate on in on this axis and engagement
on this access
foreign
so how does this look like in a typical
month so this is a performance from a
typical month the data points are real
but there are no numbers on these axes
uh what you can see is the orange points
are the randomized control trial data
the Green Point is the model point where
we did make this decision on where we
want to be on this Frontier we decided
the value of delta and then we gave
different users different meter limits
and then we observe a performance and we
can see that this Green Point the model
Point achieves a higher conversion rate
for a given engagement level so it's
doing better than random and there is a
lift in our kpi which is the conversion
rate which is purely the machine
learning lift that we get in terms of
the extra subscriptions that we're
getting out of this model
so
to
conclude the dynamic meter assigns
personalized meter limits to registered
users a meter limit is the number of
free articles that people can get next
month before they hit a paywall
it has a dual role so it optimizes and
balances the trade-off between
engagement and subscriptions uh one
value addition of this model is that it
can adaptively tune the about trade-off
based on business guidance so we can be
adaptive to the changing new cycle
and it achieves a lift in conversion
rate as compared to a purely random
policy at the same engagement level
so that's Dynamic meter
and because I'm at Pi data I also want
to show you one slide about the text tag
that we use in different open source
tools that we that we use to power this
productionized model
and this is how our Tech stack looks
so it's all based on heavily based on
python so we use a lot of the different
packages that python Community uses for
machine learning so we start at this box
over here where we have custom machine
learning models which are based on
various packages
they're hosted on GitHub repos
um they are integrated using CI CD
continuous integration and continuous
development via drone
what drone does it is deploys code onto
Google Cloud composer which is a
completely managed service that runs
airflow and it also deploys code into
Docker images which are then run through
Docker containers and so this particular
bit helps us with enterization scaling
of machine learning models
the Google Cloud composer airflow setup
is tasked with running the machine
learning models as well as doing ETL
extract transform and load so it
interacts with a SQL database that we
have in Google bigquery where we do
store our machine learning related data
but also raw data that we can get from
an internal service called event tracker
which tracks first party site activity
data and in this particular Arrow
there's probably a lot of different
engineering teams which get us the
divided data from event tracker to the
SQL database so that it's usable for
machine learning
the machine learning models themselves
are run through communities so that they
can be Auto scaled and an output of
machine learning models is typically
some sort of files in form of csvs or
pickle files that we send to Google
Cloud Storage which has an API that
other services can call so that the
meter service is what is tasked with
actually showing paywalls to people and
so they can use our input of a number of
free articles that users get and
actually show them a paper
so in this ecosystem we make we leverage
Google Cloud platform a lot but at the
same time a lot of Open Source services
such as airflow and in this particular
bit we have a lot of machine learning
packages that are open source that we
make heavy use of and particularly
grateful to the pi data community and
I'm focused for supporting all these
open source projects
so that's all I have for today if you're
curious to know more about the uh the
the work uh we have an MIT open blog
that we recently published and if my QR
code generating abilities are correct
this should point you to that link if
you're interested in figuring that out
there are several job openings we have
relevant roles for this audience might
be data scientists data analysts machine
learning engineer and I am very happy to
take any questions thank you
thank you
all right thank you so much
um I'm here to call on people um but
yeah don't forget to
um
I don't know you you are predicting
meter rates uh per user right
and I guess I have two related comments
um how did you decide that that would be
better than predicting one overall rate
that would maximize your preferred
result rather than per user
and I guess the second Point well just a
feeling about fairness um doing one
thing for everybody versus individual
things that may or may not be accurate
or it might be
more yeah no great questions so I think
the first question is and I can probably
go back to the slide for example this
one so the first question is how did we
decide that a personalized meter limit
is going to be better than a global
meter limit for everybody and this plot
shows that so all these different orange
points are points where everybody in
this bucket got a single meter limit so
here in this point everybody got 20 free
articles in this point everybody got 100
free articles and so these are
intermediate levels and what we're
trying to do is have a machine learning
lift on top of that because maybe a
single meter limit is not good for
everybody and that different people have
different appetite for times content
some people are maybe very likely
subscribers but they just have never
seen a paywall and they would like to
support us but they've never seen a
paywall and for those we would probably
like to show them a paywall so that they
can become subscribers for us and we can
see that the personalized problem is
better in terms of the kpi for example
conversion rate because if you look at
this Green Point which is the
personalized meter limit it's better
than this point where everybody got a
global same meter limits in terms of the
conversion rate so what we're able to do
is let users read the same number of
articles but actually increase the
conversion rate which is our primary kpi
and then the second question about
fairness I think that's something that
we take very seriously we have 135
million registered users who place trust
in us and we take that seriously and we
have some ethical sort of constraints
that we've built in the model so we
don't use any demographic features or
psychographic features in this model
it's all about engagement data it's all
about how much you have interacted with
our website or app and that's how these
meter limits are decided and we think
that this is fair and also this model
does not take into account what the
users have read so it's not that we are
blocking People based on a particular
class of articles that they would like
to read so in that way we do believe
that we have fairness into account and
we also have an algorithmic Ethics
program inbuilt which actually evaluates
our machine learning models for biases
against protected class because we don't
include those features directly but they
can indirectly pop in because of
correlations in the data and we would
like to evaluate these models and we
have an algorithics program that we try
to run our models through so that we can
assess their biases hope that answers
the question
my question
correctly
correctly trained the model on the
randomized control trials and then if so
why not train on like a blend of
randomized controlled trials plus the
actions
yeah so the question is do we train our
models only on the randomized control
trial data and why not use previous
model model allocated meter limits also
in that and yeah we train the model only
on randomized Control Data because we
want this to be a causal model so that
the MC is a causal variable and we can
make an accurate prediction of what
would happen in these different
counterfactory scenarios I believe there
are techniques where you can use
non-randomized data and W robust
learning is one example and that's
something that we have kind of played
around with but we have never really
pushed into production
um it's just because I think we feel
comfortable in the amount of data we
have the RCT right now but if that gets
a constraint and you want to push the
RCT and shrink it even further then
that's something that we could consider
so that we can make model prescriptions
for a larger population but at this
stage we feel comfortable with the
proportions that we have and that's
partially because you feel that you have
enough data from the randomized control
exactly so we have a large registered
user base and we can set the allocation
so that we have enough data samples that
we can make accurate predictions
as someone who uses New York Times
multiple times a day I'm just curious
that you have any observations around
like demographic trades so a number of
other articles someone will read before
they subscribe I don't know
um
yeah so the question is if we have any
demographic insights into how the model
works if I'm understanding correctly and
yeah as I said we don't use demographic
features in the model to so for example
age or where the request is coming from
from a geographic location we do not use
those in that information in this
specific model and this precisely
because we want to protect those uh
those particular traits and not make
decisions on based on uh whether
somebody somebody's gender or somebody's
age so we don't do that
um that would be the short answer I
think
uh the gray shirt right there
okay yep
uh well my comment is on the training
paper
how
how do you deal with the fact that
you're in your historical data
Optimum
and um
right thank you um if I'm understanding
correctly I guess your question is about
how do you account for variations in the
data that have occurred historically
because we are sort of in the news
business and that's a good question
which is precisely why we train on
recent data and we have some sample
weights that we provide so more recent
data is weighted more and historical
data is weighted less so we are able to
adapt to the changing environment
because for example this month and last
month there was increased activity
because of Elections and so we would
like to set our limits based on that um
so if I understood your question
correctly the answer
effectively uh do you have any specific
users that you're using to turning users
as an email website is that considered
a new set of user data or is it like
going back to the same bucket if they
have like I don't know unsubscribed and
then subscribed again that's the first
question and then to begin with for your
randomized trial you use a unique ID or
is it like her name like how do you
control if someone's like you know it's
like keep returning or just keep on
subscribing how do you call that thing
yeah so the question is if somebody
subscribes and then unsubscribes which
bucket do they fall in and I would say
the bucket that they've Fallen is the
registered status so they would go
through this model and they would be
treated as a registered user but the
model accounts for that by tracking
features like whether they had
subscribed in the past and we believe
that that's something right to do
because they had subscribed in the past
so their subscription propensity is
probably large to subscribe in the
future so we do account for that
um and I'm sorry I'm forgetting the
second question
IDs right um yeah so internally we have
an extremely strong data engineering
team which Maps users to their unique
IDs in the register status once they
move to their subscription status there
is another ID that they get and there is
linking involved so we can we can
definitely know which registered users
subscribe and if they went back uh did
they unsubscribe and so on so that's
that's that's not us that's the data
engineering team that does that and
that's that's amazing
okay
uh how do you deal with like a cold
start problem of a single user if
they're like a fresh red person user or
does that even exist in your data if you
can like become registered by using like
your Facebook login so you have some
metadata about what they've visited for
that yeah I think so new users are
probably their own class of users and
they have a default meter limit that
they get and we do so that's decided by
the business and we do account for that
in the model so when doing historical
tests at that point there are some new
users and we assign them these default
meter limits so that's a part of the
model and then that affects the
performance and then we can make
decisions about what this default meter
limit should be otherwise so in that way
it's accounted for but yeah we don't
have too much data for them in the past
so we don't use that directly to
um you know train the model
an extension of this the same question
so
um because you're dealing with first
party data there is always a chance you
might lose the cookie information and
you know let's say if I have I've had
like five uh
is one week and if my cooking
information is gone then I come
back so basically I know I get back to
the default so I can view five more so
how does like how do you account for the
cookie information loss and on
yeah so I guess the question is
um if a user logs in and logs out how do
we account for this information uh so
yeah I think the short answer is that we
do use information in the logged in
status so if you do log out you're going
to get a meter limit which is for your
unregistered status and if you log back
in uh we would use that information to
then decide the meter limit and I think
that's fair because when you log in
you've placed some trust in Us in terms
of sharing your information with us we
only use the information that's in the
registered status that you have but then
that doesn't mean that you'd get extra
free articles because in your
unregistered status as well there's a
separate meter limit that you have so
that would block you otherwise
okay yeah I was wondering uh maybe this
is somewhat anti-fairness to your policy
but is there a team that's doing this
but for price discrimination
um it's optimizing for subscribers of
course but you might try and find an
optimal that's
not based purely on that Dimension yeah
so I think that's a good question and
you know I can't answer that directly
but what I can tell you is that the
algorithmic targeting team does think
about problems like that because we are
thinking about a subscriber in the
entire subscription life cycle and so
that entire subscription funnel so there
are interesting problems in their entire
funnel of how to get unregistered people
to the registered status registered
people to the subscription status and of
course when you are subscribers any
business that has a subscription
business has to have a churn model to
understand when people might churn so
there are these different areas that the
algorithmic targeting team is tasked
with but I can't get into the specifics
of Which models because I personally
work on this model
one type of one more how about you yeah
um thank you so much see can you speak
some more to um you were talking about
doing some um like retrospective
evaluation and for those
um you do are trying to evaluate against
some counter factuals and he's briefly
touched on that but uh is wondering what
degree of similar age is it does it have
similarity to kind of um puzzle analysis
of relational data in the sense of you
know matching and other kinds of
techniques yeah yeah I think I think
that there are matching techniques that
we could use for this same problem for
sure uh I think the interesting thing
here is that we do have access to
randomized data so you're describing
something where you're where you do some
retrospective analysis right for
um
placing counterfections
uh let me try to get to the slide oh I
think I went the other way sorry
yeah right here so if we did not have
this past randomized control trial data
then we would make use of those
observational causal techniques to
actually do matching because then there
would be a probability of a particular
user getting a meter limit and so I
think the previous question was about
model allocations and if you include
previous model data in this then we
would like to use
um you know inverse propensity weighting
and things like that what we do is we
use specifically RCT data so we do have
a probability that we know because we
set up the RCT of when this matching
will actually occur so we already know
we don't have to predict that
probability we just know it exactly and
so in that sense this is matching but we
actually know the probabilities
um yeah all right so that's all we have
time for for this session thank you so
much Rohit that was really fast thank
you